ya hablamos sobre que la molécula de
agua tiene polaridad un lado tiene una
carga parcial negativa y el otro lado
tiene cargas parciales positivas también
hablamos de como esto nos lleva a los
puentes de hidrógeno y mencionamos que
quizá esos puentes de hidrógeno son los
que le dan ciertas propiedades al agua
pero de lo que quiero hablar en este
vídeo este una de esas propiedades
importantes que es la habilidad del agua
para actuar como un solvente solvente
esto significa que es fácil que ciertas
cosas sean disueltas en agua y eso es
muy importante porque así es como ocurre
en muchas cosas químicas es decir
disolviendo cosas en agua y después
interactuando con otras cosas eso es lo
que ocurre adentro de las células
adentro del citoplasma el citoplasma que
es mayormente agua es un solvente que
permite que ocurran un montón de
interacciones entre diferentes tipos de
moléculas pero primero hablemos de por
qué
es un buen solvente y veamos qué tipo de
cosas se pueden disolver fácilmente y
cuáles no la clave que hace que el agua
sea un buen solvente es su polaridad por
ejemplo si tomamos un poco de cloruro de
sodio conocido comúnmente como sal de
mesa tenemos un poco de nhl verá el
sodio y el cloro están unidos por un
enlace iónico el sodio tiene una carga
positiva porque le quitaron sus
electrones y el cloro es una unión es
decir tiene una carga negativa porque
ganó electrones estos dos se atraen éste
tiene una carga positiva y este tiene
una carga negativa a esto se le conoce
como enlace iónico pero qué pasa si
ponemos el cloruro de sodio en agua
bueno es algo muy interesante si ponemos
sal de mesa en agua la sal se disuelve
pero porque se disuelve bueno vamos a
ver
este es el sodio sodio tiene una carga
positiva y por acá pongamos al cloro el
cloro tiene una carga negativa que
pasará al ponerlos en agua bueno
imaginen que las terminales parcialmente
negativas de las moléculas de agua serán
atraídas a lyon de sodio entonces
veremos algo como esto oxígeno oxígeno
oxígeno no estoy dibujando a escala solo
es para que se den una idea esta parte
de la molécula de agua tiene una carga
parcial negativa parcial negativa
parcial negativa
y son atraídas a lyon de sodio cargado
positivamente mientras que los
hidrógenos que tienen una carga parcial
positiva son repelidos los hidrógenos
son repelidos por el ión de sodio
positivo
y nos queda algo así y bueno tenemos
cargas parciales positivas en todos los
hidrógenos así que todos estos
hidrógenos interactúan con el agua
formando puentes de hidrógeno entonces
el sodio que tenemos aquí es unión tiene
una carga y por lo tanto puede
disolverse en el agua muy fácilmente
porque es atraído a las terminales
parcialmente negativas de la molécula de
agua y algo similar ocurre con el ión de
cloro que al ser negativo le podemos
llamar año voy a mover el cloro para que
tengamos más espacio
ahí está entonces el avión de cloro
tiene una carga negativa así que claro
será atraído a la terminal parcialmente
positiva de la molécula de agua así que
podemos imaginar algo como esto esta vez
el ión atrae a los hidrógenos porque
tienen cargas parcialmente positivas y
acá tenemos el oxígeno que tiene una
carga parcial negativa y podemos dibujar
más moléculas de agua acá tenemos otros
hidrógenos y su oxígeno por acá tenemos
otros hidrógenos recuerden este no es un
dibujo a escala y aquí tenemos el
oxígeno así nos quedan moléculas de agua
alrededor de lyon donde la terminal
positiva que son los átomos de hidrógeno
son atraídos al guión negativo aquí
tenemos parcial positivo mientras que la
parte parcial negativa nos que
hacia afuera y podrá interactuar con el
agua de la misma forma que interactúa
cualquier otra molécula de agua así
podrá fluir fácilmente ahora aquí hay
algo muy interesante si algo tiene carga
como unión o simplemente es algo que
tiene polaridad será muy fácil
disolverlo en agua y en este caso el
agua es el solvente el agua es nuestro
solvente
y a lo que estamos disolviendo en el
agua le vamos a llamar soluto el cloruro
de sodio es nuestro soluto podemos decir
que el cloruro de sodio es el soluto o
también el ion de sodio y los anones de
cloro se consideran solutos entonces qué
cosas se disuelven bueno pues todo lo
que tenga carga o que sea polar podrá
disolverse en agua y como se disuelven
en agua se dice que son hidrofílicos
podemos decir que esto es hidrofílico
hidrofílico
hidro se refiere al agua
y filippo significa amante así que es un
amante del agua algo que es hidrofílico
ama el agua pero vamos a ver ya hablamos
de las moléculas de agua de polaridad
también vimos los iones y podemos
entender por qué son hidrofílicos y cómo
es que se pueden incorporar fácilmente
en el agua pero cuáles serían algunos
ejemplos de cosas que no se disuelvan en
agua tan fácilmente bueno en general son
las cosas que no tienen carga o que no
son polares como es el caso de los
hidrocarburos si por ejemplo tenemos
hexano que es el constituyente principal
de la gasolina de la palabra hexano el
prefijo ex significa que hay 6 carbonos
tenemos 1 2 3
4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 carbones y todos los
demás enlaces son hidrógenos vamos a
ponerlos
recuerden que el carbono puede formar
cuatro enlaces hidrógeno hidrógeno
hidrógeno hidrógeno hidrógeno hidrógeno
este es el hexano observen que esta
molécula no tiene polaridad no forma
puentes de hidrógeno
entonces si agregamos hexano al agua no
se va a disolver por ejemplo si ustedes
ponen un poco de gasolina en agua no se
va a disolver entonces a todo esto que
no se puede disolver le vamos a llamar
hidrofóbico esta molécula es hidrofóbica
no le gusta el agua y como el agua se
atrae a sí misma pero no siente
atracción por esta molécula hidrofóbico
quiere decir hidro de agua y fóbicos
significa miedo así que esta molécula le
tiene miedo al agua por eso es tan
difícil mezclar agua y aceite o gasolina
y agua